hated toilet seats the first time i went
to japan and tried a heated toilet seat
so i'm just like
how is the rest of the first world
[ __ ] like
uh other first world countries haven't
caught haunted yeah i won't lie i think
i have actually ruined toilets for
myself because whenever i go to a toilet
now that doesn't have a bidet
i legit feel like i have a panic attack
i legit feel like how am i supposed to
wash my ass clean
wipe it are you kidding me i'm not an
animal i don't touch that area
do i if i ever move back to the uk no
joke i'm a hundred percent invest in a
better
the suitcase is empty dude i'm making
room for the premium
1 000 bidet because i'm using that [ __ ]
daily i want a [ __ ] like a king yeah
and like i remember pro zd i was talking
to him as well one time he was like
dude when he went back from when he came
back from japan the one thing he brought
was a bidet
because he was like i i insist i feel
him he he has taste man yeah he
he was arguing he's like i insist that i
[ __ ] like a king and i'm like
honestly i completely understand it
because once you get used to a bidet and
you get the heated seat
you know you get the you get a little
pressure washer you can have it set to
like boom
boom boom go back and forth on your ass
cheeks it's nice yeah
i might my ass feels permanently clean
why wouldn't i want to shower for my ass
every time i [ __ ]
like are you kidding me sometimes i
don't even [ __ ] but i do it cause i'm
like why don't clean my ass
why not why i got time i got some time i
want to make my ass feel refreshed
because you know sometimes right men
you have those days where like it's it's
a hot day you get like swamp ass
you know what i mean yeah well your ass
just gets kind of sweaty yeah
like no it's not even bad but just a
little bit right you're like why not
just
yeah your butt she's getting a little
stuck okay so you see so you thought
okay i
i i completely miss on this so you're
not talking about it's heated
the heated seat is also amazing you're
talking about because yeah the bidet and
but
the heated seats part of the bidet
package yeah even the cheapest ones okay
i i don't use the washing ass washing
function of the bidet at all why not i
[ __ ]
it just it just doesn't feel clean it
doesn't i don't know it's glass
got the water shooting up your ass and
then you stop it and then you just gotta
[ __ ] you just got it you just got away
so you get some of the toilet paper and
you just dry it a little bit yeah you
dry it off
it's that's yeah because like you need
the toilet paper but it doesn't feel
clean without that wipe like yeah but
okay some of them that's what you have
to watch some of them have dryers
and those are pretty good no no no i i
have you tried have you tried
i have tried [ __ ] off i have tried no no
no okay yeah because
there's a difference between wiping to
dry or why are we talking about
sparkling there's a difference in wiping
to dry your ass
and wiping to get the [ __ ] out yeah yeah
they're very different types of wipes
right one is one is like a deep life and
the other is like a shallow
excavation look look the other is a pat
down look look toilet
papers were not designed to wipe wet
arses
no because you're actually listening
your ass isn't the [ __ ] like amazon
river dude it's a it's a little
moist yeah yeah yes what i hate is when
when you have a wet house after bidet
you go to you go to wipe it and the
toilet paper just [ __ ] disintegrates
on your hands bro what what
are you using what are you [ __ ] like
using okay
how much how much water can your [ __ ]
in vertical position
contain and second of all [ __ ] toilet
paper
how many sheets of paper is used in it
yeah right you can use
like one square and be like [ __ ] it
doesn't [ __ ] matter
anyone who lives in asia doesn't matter
anyone who lives in asia knows that
toilet paper here is
weak as [ __ ] that sounds broke
as [ __ ] you sound broke right now gone
i'm probably hoping
i thought like because i thought it was
just it was just a thai thing where
toilet paper was just like [ __ ]
flaccid no
i moved to japan and toilet paper here
is like [ __ ] weak because you can't
buy the good [ __ ] yeah you get the
double play [ __ ] and then you do like
maybe like one wrap around your hair
yeah yeah that's more than enough to
absorb
any amount of liquid that's down here
you pile on three little sheets yeah
yeah right that's a
nice nickname right there two plymouths
like at least like that thing and then
just get under there it won't rip
good and yeah and your ass is clean and
it's dry i i cannot believe
you would come here like because
honestly but day is in the top three
things about japan if i'm gonna be
honest with you yeah heated
seats bidets the whole like [ __ ]
experience
yeah these top three the whole toilet
experience it's like a top three
japanese thing for me man like it's just
great
okay and another thing i look forward to
another thing about bidets as well
like it shoots up right up your [ __ ]
right that's exactly what i want and
then you just feel like you have
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] out water and so
like
how gaped is your [ __ ] so you're like
do you like goats yeah he's like
like just sit down there's just [ __ ]
water stuck in your ass
are you like giving yourself like a
prostate massage on a big day like no
it's just like it's just a natural
because you get water stuck in your anus
no no i mean how do you do that it's
your what are you
[ __ ] like are you are you are you
putting your [ __ ] over the bidet like
thing like are you are you putting it in
yeah you're putting the hose in no but
the stream of water is [ __ ] strong
enough put that down
why are you like well like you probably
set it to like [ __ ] pressure hose
public fountain no no because because if
it's not strong
then it's just a [ __ ] trickle on your
ass and that's not cleaning up sure it's
called medium yeah yeah
you need the [ __ ] pressure to [ __ ]
clean that [ __ ] up
but if it has enough pressure to clean
the [ __ ] off your ass then you're
getting water stuck in your [ __ ]
there is no in-between no i have my my
bidet is on the [ __ ]
max pressure and it's perfect yeah
because like because
because you can feel the [ __ ] coming off
and
i mean i don't know about you but my ass
[ __ ] iron clad [ __ ] right here man
just clench it a bit yeah
i collected because if you clench then
you're not [ __ ] cleaning it properly
you're crunching when you're [ __ ]
what are you being
wait you're not cleaning it properly
when you clench of course you are yeah
what do we like clench
wait you clench when you [ __ ] bidet
that [ __ ] is it like a little bit
a little bit again i know
god is like god is like relax my anus
allow the waters to flow in like
you're giving yourself a [ __ ] like
that's what it feels like it doesn't say
it feels like i'm getting it i'm taking
a [ __ ] birthday enema everything is
totally wrong oh my god
wait because like i don't clench when i
[ __ ]
what do you mean what you're just like i
like gravity do its work
what is like a fun slip and slide you're
out of my life
yeah punch that's the same thing
normally no no okay that doesn't help
with the bidet it still goes up the
[ __ ] [ __ ] even even if you
[ __ ] push that [ __ ] out
like we need an anatomy of your ass yeah
yeah i need to we need an x-ray of
yourself
can we get like the day cam just to see
like what like how [ __ ] loose your
ass always when it gets bidet like
i just don't like the feeling of like
water on my ass
and i don't know so wait what about in
the shell yeah what are you cleaning
your ass with
no i okay so you you know you know when
you clean your ass gone yeah i clean my
[ __ ] heart
you talked about the sweaty you talked
about the sweaty feeling yeah
yeah if i guess one person i just take a
[ __ ] shower i don't even forget that
[ __ ]
yeah that's so unnecessary i can take i
can take three showers god takes
one [ __ ] it goes home he's like [ __ ] got
a shower now
honestly honestly like sometimes if i
want to feel clean after a [ __ ] i just
take a [ __ ] shower man
quick five quick fight what are you
doing in this toilet
you're like you got gone is that one
dude when you leave some
public restrooms there's like a [ __ ]
war zone yeah that must be gone
that that is no the [ __ ] everywhere [ __ ]
on the wall
it's like that is gone it's gone going
in there it's like [ __ ] in places you
didn't think [ __ ] would end up
i'm not it's the [ __ ] opposite why
would i use a bidet when they can't
reach me
like my shits are like the cleanest
shits you know they
they they are there's no such thing as a
clean [ __ ] wait
okay no have you never had like the
perfect [ __ ]
the no wipes yeah yeah like like the
squishy is like the perfect
the perfect [ __ ] which was just like you
just [ __ ] out a log and it's like
one solid clean log and then you look at
it and it's like no
wipe you look at it and you're just like
man that's a [ __ ] piece of art right
in my family we call that the swish
because it doesn't touch the sides
during this episode yo i just did a
swish right there man
you don't need a [ __ ] day after you
did that [ __ ] swish man i mean
i still like it though i still do it
anyway because it feels good to me
that is like the equivalent right of
coming to japan and just being like yeah
man i just ate only kfc and burger king
it's like you've wasted the true
potential of japan like what have you
done
like you you it is it is on par honestly
with food
something about japan like food is
amazing and the [ __ ] experience is
also goblin
i i i actually look forward to taking a
[ __ ] i can't wait to crack open the
bidet and
just feel amazing
crack open up the day with the boys
crack open the booty you know
and just have a great [ __ ] time yeah
[ __ ] for pleasure honestly i do honestly
i used to [ __ ] because it was a bodily
function
now i look forward to my shits yeah
cause it's japan and they've they
figured out how to make [ __ ] an
enjoyable experience
i look forward to shooting for like
other reasons like the bidet is just
like
the other reason that you have a warm
ass yeah well one i have warm ass and
there's like two
[ __ ] sacred places for me and one is
the shower and the other one is when i'm
taking the [ __ ]
right now probably probably like my
channel wouldn't it wouldn't exist if i
couldn't [ __ ] or shower
yeah where the [ __ ] am i going to get my
ideas from are you having [ __ ]
existential crisis on the toilet
yes i am who doesn't do you not no
because taking a [ __ ] for me is
enjoyable
yeah that's the reason like people think
that i take such a long time to [ __ ]
because i'm having like a mental
breakdown
no i'm just having a [ __ ] great time
i'm just like why would i leave early
when i'm having this much fun right here
it's so fun i [ __ ] love [ __ ] the
days i just
i don't know in thailand we have like an
even worse thing which is
like it's it's it's like it's like a
self bidet right
so it's in like most southeast asian
countries we don't have like the
auto on your ass per days we have like a
little like a shower head like a mini
shower head
that you have to like put between your
legs some european countries have that
too right yeah
there's a little bowl the thing that
like the little bowl next to it or you
do it in the toilet
and it's like in this
i've always hated that feeling because
then you just get wet balls that's too
much because
because the bidet is precise with where
it ends yeah right and when you've used
your own bidet long enough you know
where
the bidet's like sniping your eyes yeah
and you know the radius of which it'll
spread yeah yeah so you've got it down
or not right
now we've talked about [ __ ] how long
have we been talking about showering our
[ __ ] because
i've always wanted to talk about on the
podcast because it's one of the no joke
the most enjoyable part of japan
i know what to call this episode now the
japanese toilet experience
the [ __ ] japanese experience i know
where a golden raccoon experience comes
from
it's when you're on the [ __ ] toilet
did you get like
did were you a bit like worried when you
first saw how [ __ ]
how to operate the bidet when you first
came to japan yeah i think a lot of
british people are because it's it's
like the thought of spraying your ass is
so foreign to us
yeah what's that thing that you and alan
did again the first time you went to the
[ __ ] uh hotel we were curious about
how the bidet knew when you were sitting
on it yeah
so with the the bathroom was like a wet
room so we were like okay well it
doesn't matter if this bidet sprays
everywhere
so we we we had like a few drinks we
like let's figure out how the bidet
works
so we figured out the bidet won't spray
unless there's pressure on the seat yeah
it's pretty [ __ ] cool
yeah and then it was like spraying on
the wall because no one was sitting on
it
this thing was going far it was spraying
oh yeah it was crazy that's
that's the pressure that's what i want
going
in australia we always had a bidet
because my mom was like i can't live
without a bidet so
because she's japanese and she's [ __ ]
like a king why don't you go back she's
like
she's like let me teach you let me teach
you australians how to [ __ ] like a king
so we had it in our in our house but
of course when i was little i didn't use
the bidet right because
i didn't know what the [ __ ] it was i was
just like all buttons but i didn't i
didn't [ __ ] press any of them
i remember first time seeing a bidet and
i'm just like yo do i need to
do i need a license to operate this [ __ ]
license it's like i feel like if i if i
press the wrong button like this
toilet's going to take off like
here here is like the [ __ ] operating
system of the bidet that you can see on
screen right now
especially like going to japan the first
time and it's all in the yeah but
basically like when i was little like i
never
knew how to use the bidet right because
i always just learned to like just make
sure to wipe and wash your hands and
then you'll be good
yeah but you know when you get to like
around like age six or seven you start
to get a little bit curious what these
buttons are you're just like
what i wonder what this is so i did the
fatal mistake though so i i pushed the
the bidet
like start the day but yeah but i made
the fatal mistake getting up off my seat
and looking down at the toilet box oh no
you spray you in the face so [ __ ]
sprayed me in the eye
and there's just water going everywhere
and i'm like i don't know how to stop
this what the [ __ ] happening i
actually thought i broke my toilet
so i called my mom and i'm just like mom
come here she came in
[ __ ] bidet water going everywhere in
this toilet she's just like what the
[ __ ]
and then the last thing she said like
she finally stopped it and she's like
you could have at least like flush your
[ __ ] man like i
didn't see that but also the bidet water
is also warm
yeah so it's literally like a warm
shower it is like a warm shell
only w's only w and the thing is right
is that
you know if you're an american or you're
just a westerner in general and you come
and you see this toilet yeah it can be
daunting right because
yeah you know normally things don't go
near your ass you're not used to that no
no
just embrace it it feels good you know
it's scary
but once you want once you admit that
things feel good when they spray your
ass yeah
that's like a reservoir it's like it's
like discovering a new fetish
just give it a go yeah does it feel a
little erotic
i mean it does but it you know if it
feels good
the wet ass afterwards just doesn't feel
good try it just dry it just try it man
that's what i'm talking about it doesn't
feel clean i don't know my [ __ ]
doesn't feel properly
like i don't feel properly clean after a
wipe i feel like ninety percent clean
after a while yeah cause you know
there's always gonna be a little bit
left
right right like you know that bidet is
scraping that [ __ ] it's like washing
your hands without soap it's like you
might feel clean but you don't
really until you use that soap i know i
need to physically feel
my [ __ ] being clean and not like
getting it washed i don't know
i need to feel that [ __ ] man i need to
confirm with my own hands
that's what you should do you should use
the bidet and then wipe it with your
hand
and see if it's still not because like
it doesn't feel properly clean to me
unless i [ __ ] shower like my [ __ ]
never feels clean
unless i shower and i properly soap in
it this man's like wasting [ __ ]
buckets of water to clean his ass i i
only could just be using a bidet